the holiday season is one of Charity and
today 8 news now kicked off the great
food drive with Smith's and your
donations benefit the non-profit project
150. Ted florindo is there live with
more hi Ted how's it going hey hi guys
good afternoon to you of course we told
you about the great food drive something
that eight news now is very passionate
about we've teamed up with Smith's in
Project 150 and if you go to any Smiths
you will see these boxes near the front
near the entrance and we ask you to
please please make a donation
non-perishable food items in these boxes
because it will benefit project 150.
look at down here at Smith's people have
already donated we love that we love
seeing that but I've been to several
Smiths where those boxes are empty and
we need more if you're figuring out and
trying to wonder wondering what is
Project 150 here's why we're passionate
about it okay project 150 is an
organization that actually helps high
school students displaced homeless
disadvantaged high school students get a
meal so they can go to school they they
can study high school is hard enough so
can you imagine going to school on an
empty stomach trying to study this is
why we're passionate about it this is
why we need your help and we need to
fill these boxes up to help those kids
here in Clark County get that meal as
they go to school that is for project
150. okay we want to show you the
temperatures outside right now first we
begin with your current conditions out
this hour we have some high thin clouds
we did touch in the 60s good to see that
temperatures are now starting to drop
winds staying light good to see that too
that of course is going to change later
on this week how about that travel
forecast because a lot of us are going
to be traveling ready to hit the
airports right here's how it looks not
too bad for Thanksgiving travel on
Wednesday most of the lower 48 good
however things not so good for those
areas near the Northern Plains states
Big Sky country there in Montana we'll
watch Florida and also the Carolinas
make sure you check with your Airlines
on any airport delays but most of the
lower 48 looks pretty good your weather
now satellite and radar notice clouds
coming in from the West we'll see those
thick and more overnight but notice on
the radar there are no Echoes coming
back so things will remain dry more
impacts though for Seattle and Portland
that will be on Thanksgiving as another
storm blankets that area with more rain
and also some high elevation snow your
current wind forecast does show light
winds for tonight light winds for
tomorrow however look at Wednesday those
winds will begin to pick up again well
we will have Breezy winds at times
especially down the Colorado River
Valley Breezy winds at times for the
valley here with also those Northerly
winds big and stronger winds from the
north for those Northern neighborhoods
like up here in Centennial hills Aliante
of course Nellis North Las Vegas as well
how about your eight news now forecast
for Thanksgiving check this out
temperatures will be in the high 60s to
Mid 60s warmer than we've seen these
past few days in fact Thanksgiving could
be our warmest day in the eight day
forecast winds like we said will pick up
that day as well especially in the
morning for dinner time not so much
still some breezes around from the north
but temperatures will be quite mild as
well back live now again we're asking
you to donate when you see these boxes
at any of the Smiths that you go to
there's a Smith throughout the valley
you're probably very close to one 44 of
them make a donation today and help them
out I'll have more coming up on eight
news now at four reporting live in Sky
Canyon 10th lorendo eight news now back
to you well thank you Ted you can drop
off non-perishable food items at any
Smith's location our 8 news now team
will continue to be at the Smith's
Marketplace at Sky Canyon all day
collecting your donations the great food
drive runs through December 2nd Las
Vegas now